salut la team menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui
pour ce samedi je vous apprends à
bluffer quelqu'un un petit truc une
petite astuce on pourra même dire un
petit tour en fait entre la magie et le
mentalisme ces partis génériques
il ya quelque chose que je faisais à mes
amis voire à ma famille quand j'étais
petit et qui a toujours étonné tout le
monde et personne n'a jamais compris
comment je faisais je présentais ça
comme étant une prédiction incroyable
alors qu'en fait il y avait une
technique très simple pour ça et c'est
ça que je vais vous apprendre vous allez
avoir le pouvoir de prédire la fin d'une
partie de dominos concrètement vous
allez sortir un jeu de domino si vous
n'avez pas de jeu de dominos on y
reviendra après vous allez tout mélanger
et vous dites la personne en face de
vous j'aimerais que tu construis toute
la partie parce qu'on va pas se mentir
il n'y a pas plus simple qu'un jeu de
domino comme règle via une red sea 1,5
ici il faut que l'autre domino commence
par 1,5
la cie c13 faut que le dôme ne commence
par un 3 etc etc
donc vous dites à la personne tu doit
relier tous les dominos tu dois faire
une partie avec tous les dominos il doit
pas en rester un seul à la fin mais moi
en tant que grand prédicateur est
heureux je vais écrire sur un bout de
papier qu'elle l'est le domino qui va
commencer et quel est le domino qui va
finir je vais prédire ça tout simplement
comme ça de bon matin effectivement vous
serez en mesure de le faire avec une
petite embrouille rapaces le cache
quelque chose que vous ne savez pas
forcément c'est qu'un jeu de dominos
complet doit pouvoir faire une boucle
c'est à dire que si on met bien tous les
dominos à la suite en utilisant tous les
dominos alors on referme complètement le
dernier par exemple ce serait 1 2 alors
que vous vous aviez commencé par un 2 et
pourrait se rejoindre ça c'est la
méthode même de construction des dominos
donc si un jeu de dominos est toujours
complet si on enlève un domino par
inadvertance au début de la partie avant
même qu'elle ne commence alors ce domino
peut vous servir de prédiction exemple
très concret si j'enlève a dominé 6 1 ça
veut dire que les deux extrémités du jeu
de dominos fut entièrement à la fin sera
6 et 1 puisque ça aurait dû pouvoir se
rejoindre et il est balèze ce qui est
d'ailleurs super c'est que vous pouvez
refaire le tour tout de suite après en
remettant le domino vous aviez enlevé en
en prenant un autre discrètement donc
récapitulatif vous prenez un jeu de
dominos complet vous le mettez sur la
table vous mélangez vous mélangez au
prélat vous en avez retiré 1 et vous
savez lequel c'est vous prenez un papier
un crayon vous marquez votre prédiction
les deux extrêmes de la partie de
dominos seront 6
c'est ainsi vous avez enlevé le 6 juin
vous confier ça à quelqu'un d'autre la
personne en face de vous doit faire le
jeu de dominos en utilisant tous les
dominos et fin de la partie on déplie
papier et ça correspond aux extrêmes si
vous n'avez pas de dominos ce sont des
choses qui arrivent à vous en faites
vous prenez une grande feuille a4 le jeu
vous fait un petit pour l'exemple vous
dessinez de larges bandes que vous
découper et puis ensuite vous faites
vous même vous même vos domino la seule
règle c'est que vous devez respecter que
les jointures soit identique donc la cij
mais de là je remets de là vous devez
juste faire en sorte que comme dans un
vrai jeu de dominos le dernier soit
identique au premier
donc là par exemple si je faisais que
trois domino là je finirai par un 1 ici
pour que ça puisse faire une boucle
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo du
samedi matin j'espère que ça vous aura
plu j'ai rien dit pour ceux qui veulent
me voir en spectacle je joue la semaine
prochaine en suisse à lausanne vous avez
toutes les infos sur mon site internet
dont le lien est dans la description
jour par leur un petit peu plus de ça la
semaine prochaine parce qu'on est en
train de mettre des choses en place pour
lausanne passe un excellent week-end
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir et rendez vous de
ma lalalala 11h ciao